all right let's go to dan in cedar
rapids iowa dan the man what's up
hi john thanks for taking my call um
really looking forward to
to talking with you um a little nervous
also
hey i'm nervous too man i get nervous
all the time so it's all good so how can
i help brother
so a couple weeks ago my dad was
diagnosed with
liver cancer oh hold on hold on stop
what's up
can we just say that sucks yeah
have you sat down and just looked in the
mirror and looked in your own eyeballs
and just said
this sucks yes
yes and no um it just seems like i'm
taking
the diagnosis a little harder than than
my dad is
um growing up in a farming family you
were
conditioned to to show not show your
emotions
did you say a fireman family uh a
farming family farming family okay
farming family
yep and it just seems like yeah you
weren't supposed to
to show your emotions and and now it
just seems like it's
it's all coming out for me and
taking over taking over my life it seems
like
sure so how old are you man so 28
28. are you married you got kids yup
well i just recently married um
got married back in in august so uh no
kids as of right now
yet but um they're on their way or
that's that's in the the coming future
very cool
so tell me about your old man so
yeah he's 74 years old
and um he's one of those guys that
that that everyone likes a heart of gold
hard worker um
just just an all-around good guy it's
awesome he's a good dad to you
yeah yeah we we talk on the phone
probably
multiple times a day um
y'all did before the diagnosis what's
that y'all talk to
y'all talk that often before the
diagnosis
oh yeah yeah america listen
talk to your kids a couple of times a
day
cop talk to your kids a couple of times
a week good for you man
good for you and your dad yeah so it it
doesn't seem like we're trying to make
up for lost time
sure but it's all right this is what
we're facing
and all right what are we going to do to
go forward
um yeah this
yeah the cancer diagnosis it doesn't
phase him
at all even though that
he knows that it's it's on his liver and
potentially throughout the rest of his
body um hey let me let me tell you a
secret
about dads it absolutely phases him
it absolutely terrifies him
it absolutely breaks his heart
okay don't for one second let that iowa
farmer
the guy that just puts on his car hearts
and his overalls and gets back in the
tractor every day
don't let that stoic face trick you
he's already thinking about how much
he's going to miss you how much he's
going to miss his wife
he's hoping he gets to see a grandkid
trust me
it's it's it does faze him okay
and the reason that's important for you
to know because right now you probably
feel crazy don't you
because he's just plugging along as
though it's another wednesday as though
it's another friday as though it's
another sunday and you just want to
scream out dude you've got cancer
right
is that fair yeah yeah i know that's
fair and
so trust me when i tell you it faithes
him
now he may be a little more clinical
about it farmers deal with death their
whole lives
right and so there is something somewhat
poetic about it and beautiful about it
and routine about it
but it phases him okay so how are you
feeling man
all over the place
[Music]
yeah all over the place it's so i also
work off the farm as well and
it's it's one of those things that's
always on the front of your mind
you can't google the symptoms or
google liver cancer and and see the
prognosis
sure yeah we're kind of kind of all over
the place
um but well actually right now he's
he's having a a biopsy and so he's good
we're waiting to to find out what kind
of cancer
it is to start in the liver or does it
move to the liver so we're just kind of
all up in the air and
whether it's a really rough prognosis
or whether it is a cheerful
best case scenario
your dad still loves you and you still
love your dad
right oh absolutely and whether you've
got
six months left with them or 16 years
left with them
that won't change what will change
is whether you want to lean into those
last few moments
and love him recklessly
leave nothing unsaid no hug ungiven
or whether you want to lean into the the
remaining time
again whether it's 16 years or six
months
you want to lean into that time
cautiously as though he's fragile
as though you don't want to say the
wrong thing or hug too tightly
or or what you have here man is
something that very few people have
anymore
and that is a ironclad deep-rooted
relationship
between a father and a son where they
talk to one another
it's not imaginary it's not pretend
you all do hard work together outside
with your hands
and so make no mistake when he passes
away one day what you will
it's gonna be hard and it's going to be
difficult
and he's also going to have raised you
to be strong
and resilient and heartbroken
and strong and resilient and sad
and all those things together again and
again and over and over
right
and so if you could say anything to your
old man right now he was sitting across
from you
and we we taped his mouth shut so he
couldn't
go oh oh oh oh see he couldn't say
anything
what would you tell him oh
that's like
thank you for thank you for being there
and being good dad
i can think of few things in the world
few things in the world i'd rather hear
than my son looked me in the eye and
said hey
you are a good dad and he'd probably rip
that tape off and say i don't know what
you're talking about the worst stuff i
still am a good dad
right yeah yeah
so here's what's coming for you
a lot of feelings all of which are valid
not all of which are true
okay okay you're going to feel
all kinds of things you're going to
range from frustrated that he's not
going to do his will the right way
or he's going to have some ideas about
selling this tractor before
whatever you're going to have all these
kind of nuts and bolts things they're
going to drive you batty
some of that will be because he's it's
his and he can do what he wants some of
that's just going to be because you're
struggling with grief
you probably didn't get a great model
for what
uh grieving looks like
you probably didn't get a great model
for what vulnerability and feelings look
like
and so i want you to lean heavily into
your new marriage
and i want you to tonight tell your wife
i'm going to start practicing something
i've never done before
and that is i'm going to tell you how i
feel
and it's not always true and it's not
always correct but i'm just going to
practice doing this and she'll say okay
great and then it's going to be
weird for both of you because she
married an iowa farmer knowing what she
got right and so this you're changing
the game for everybody
right but something you could give to
your children
something you could give to your wife is
something that few of us
know how to do which is be vulnerable
and be honest
sit in our feelings but don't bathe in
them right they don't become us
but we experience them and then we move
on because they lie to us they're not
always truthful
and then you can go be fully present
with your dad not speaking of him in the
past tense
but sitting right there with him when he
gets whatever diagnosis he's gonna get
yeah right is your mom still around
oh yeah yeah yeah mom's still around
luckily mom just retired back in
beginning of october so she can go
through this this entire process
with him um and it's a little different
with with covid because you can't
can't go and see him because you don't
want him to
be battling be battling two fronts
that's right
so i want you to make a plan
for this weekend and i want you
to write your dad a letter that tells
him what he's meant to you
and i want this to be before the
diagnosis comes out
and that way you're not writing him a
goodbye letter
you're not writing him a praise god
letter
you're just writing him a letter between
father and son
it just says thank you so much for being
my dad
you did a great job and here's the thing
over the next few months regardless of
what happens that letter's going to turn
into gold for him
he'll go back to it he'll go back to it
and he'll go back to it
and then as the weeks and months
progress
i want you to be direct with them how
are you feeling today
how's the chemotherapy going
how's my old man doing are you scared
i'm scared
hey new wife i woke up today and i was
scared
for my dad i was scared about the future
of the farm
can we just hug for a minute and i want
you to start making a list of things
maybe ask your dad hey what are some
things you did intentionally with me
that i can pass on to my
young son to my young daughter and let
your dad
verbalize let him teach you that all we
all
love being the one who gives advice and
gives wisdom feels good people call you
and ask you
but cherish every moment let no hug go
unhugged
let no words go unsaid
you were given one of the greatest gifts
a person could ever get
which is a lovely present father
good for you what a blessing we'll be
thinking about you during this time i do
want you to shoot me a note back
about what the diagnosis is what the
prognosis is
and then keep checking back in with us
and we'll continue to tell your story on
the air because
you're a gift dan your dad's a gift and
we want to honor him in his upcoming
months and hopefully upcoming years
thank you so much for the call